I know people welcome to the Rubin
report I'm still dave rubin and we have
a high IQ show for you it was just
confirmed you guys have done the paddle
together Cara Santa Maria max looga
we're this is a bright show you know
what I mean sometimes we're making
people dumber sometimes we're teaching I
feel this is going to be a teaching
episode you guys are you ready for some
teaching I plan to make people Dumber
today you're gonna make you dumber all
right lot of pressure are you guys all
right here we go you guys may have seen
this video that's making the rounds this
week online Microsoft is coming out with
something called the hollow lens and if
basically to me pretty much means that
the matrix is happening let's take a
look what if we could go beyond the
screen where your digital world is
blended with your real world now we can
this is the world with Holograms
what will they enable us to do
new ways to visualize our work I have an
idea for the fuel tank
new ways to share ideas with each other
how things don't you rent I just put the
images in onedrive okay
more immersive ways to play
new ways to teach and learn so put the
new trap in the place of the old one now
and tights in here and here yeah you can
call me neo because we are on our way to
being in the matrix I love these kind of
stories I love this technology stuff we
do a lot of stuff on the bad side of
technology and we're gonna do some stuff
on that later but this is all cool right
like when you were watching this did you
feel like wow the future is actually
kind of cool I'm gonna wait until i see
it i think that that's I don't know I'm
scary are you scared you thinking
machines are gonna take over no no no no
I'm just really skeptical first of all
it's not gonna look like that like I've
done a lot of stories on holography yeah
and on kind of real-time rendering a
photography none of it looks that good
yet all of that was just computers UGI
CGI cancer that's true none of that was
actual holography so right I think that
I just worried that they're trying to
sell us a product that's not going to
deliver nearly what that video says
right so you're saying at first it's
gonna look more like jittery good boy
look like help me obi-wan you're my only
hope that stuff before we get to the
full color for sure but that being said
the the technology it looks like is is
there it's not gonna be quite as pretty
it's not gonna render the right way but
the fact that we're starting to have
that integrative technology is really
cool I do wish they would have sold the
educational aspects of it a little bit
more right in that video oh this is just
to try to get us do stuff exactly like
to play minecraft in our living rooms
like that was kind of sad actually that
seemed do it I just that seemed sad that
guy doesn't get out much what do you
think I totally dig yeah I mean I think
it's awesome i first thought was way to
go Microsoft I mean it looks amazing I
think I mean obviously there's always
something lost in translation between
you know from concept to production but
I mean virtual reality it's amazing
Google glass like they're stopping
production on it yeah so what what
happened with Google glass because we
did literally probably 15 stories on it
everyone thought it was gonna be huge
I've only seen I mean we're in Los
Angeles here so we have a lot of early
adopters I've only seen one guy with it
and he was actually on a Segway to which
made him like the ultimate dork I've
ever seen and also that's what's kind of
dangerous probably probably extremely
dated but what happened I i think google
glass was like the game
of augmented reality I mean it wasn't
really that functional you know added
know sort of value to users lives other
than looking really really dorky it was
awesome yeah game boy was pretty great I
remember and I got my game with the game
gear a volunteer good reference that was
the signal in the area press here um
thank you imagine the porn yeah there
will be great porn out there in porn for
this um but really so you know I joke
about the matrix thing all the time but
like I really believe we're gonna enter
at some point we're gonna cross some
threshold here and I guess this is sort
of what ray curls walk occurs while I
was talking about with the singularity
like some point we're gonna just enter
this digital life and we're just gonna
be the batteries or this whole operation
in some ways yes I mean I think that you
can there is a dystopian future that you
can kind of envision if you've ever seen
a black mirror oh yeah I just started
watching it this week I tweeted about it
last night there's an episode that's
basically this there's an episode well
there-there's the grain episode but also
this reminds me of the episode and I
won't give anything away but where these
kids are basically in a big farm and
they're just on a bicycle all day
exercising and like playing these video
games to earn points and I think that
that it's going to be a situation where
people are gonna have to find balance
between having a healthy and nourish
body and between living in a digital
world where you don't kind of require a
lot of the the environmental and
biological um cues that you need in the
real world yeah I mean just like
recently I upgraded to the iphone 6 I
know that you guys both have the iphone
6 and I've noticed that my eyes are
starting to bother me at night really
because the screen is bigger projects a
lot more light and it doesn't filter out
the blue light at night which we know
disrupts melatonin production so that's
like also really really bad auto correct
oh yeah taro like like making up words
just fixing things it's actually making
words you name one day that we're
actually gonna have to societies too
like parallel societies because it seems
to me that obviously only people that
can afford this stuff are gonna get it
then you're gonna have people living in
this digital space and then you're gonna
have pretty much everyone else and I
know we already have the one percent and
everybody else but really we're gonna
have like a true digital we do I mean I
think we already do have a digital
divide you know something like close to
4 billion p
well don't have internet access I mean
that's crazy to think about that it's so
integrated into our lives now I don't
know what I would do without being able
to use my GPS to get somewhere without
being able to just you know Google
something Wikipedia something right away
and the fact that four billion people on
this planet were close to it now don't
have internet access I think you're
totally right and we're just gonna see
that digital divide widen and widen yeah
yeah the divide me why but I feel like
the rising tide lifts all ships you know
like the average person in in
sub-saharan Africa has better cell phone
technology in the president at 50 years
ago or some crazy style like right that
sounded about right yeah right um so
yeah so I mean I remain optimistic yeah
yeah um do you guys think that we're
gonna need at some point to actually get
away from some of this stuff cuz it's
because actually that episode of black
mirror which was pretty fantastic more
link to it in the willing to it in the
description right down there that there
was the whole point of it was sort of
was that they were losing something at
the same time that the more we go with
this digital stuff that we're losing
saying very human yeah that's a common
trope in like TV shows and movies that
use digital technology as a plot point
is this kind of disconnect to reconnect
theme which I think we all have to do
periodically to kind of take stock of
where we are in our lives to reconnect
to our families and our friends and
things like that and actually look
people straight in the face instead of
through a screen all right I'm looking
at you in the face although it is
through school no pretty good what do
you think which side of the digital
divide are you on let us know in the
comments right down below and don't
forget to subscribe in a story that
makes absolutely no sense Texas senator
Ted Cruz has just become the chairman of
the Subcommittee on space science and
competitiveness as republicans have
taken over the house yeah I had to
actually read that because it doesn't
seem possible why does this seem like an
odd choice for someone like Ted Cruz to
be heading up a science-based committee
well let's listen to his thoughts on
global warming and the problem with
climate changes there's never been a day
in the history of the world in which the
climate is not changing so you don't
believe that there is any
made a reason for global global warming
or climate change what I think is is the
data are not supporting what the
advocates are arguing the last 15 years
there has been no recorded warming
contrary to all the theories that that
they are expounding there should have
been warming over the last 15 years it
hasn't happened okay so i'm pretty sure
that that last sentence that he said is
actually not true coward can you do a
little cleaning up on that about the not
warming yeah it's completely it's just
that making [ __ ] I'm just made it gets
warm in the summer hey yeah Ted Cruz
like many people who are you know have a
political agenda snot he's not just
naive about this like he has a political
agenda to say that he doesn't believe in
global climate change we has he you know
gets lobbying money from oily yeah we'll
get we'll get to the political process
but a this is a common argument is that
they can't figure out the difference
between climate and weather and these
are two different things climate is like
general patterns weather is what happens
day-to-day yeah it warm in the summer
and cold in the winter that's not gonna
change it seems to me that the other one
that they always say the people that
don't believe in global warming or
climate change or whatever we're calling
it now they always say well I'm not a
science Oh which to me is the worst
thing that they could possibly say
because that's the purpose of having
scientists yeah scientists prove things
and look for empirical evidence and then
we're supposed to acknowledge the idea
of a technocracy as opposed to democracy
we're like you put people that are the
most adept at solving these sorts of
grand challenges in the positions where
they actually can as opposed to just
like you know republicans have the
sentence Oh Ted Cruz is now in charge of
this like really important initiative
right after thing is that the voters
voted him to this like that's what
bothers me you know this was still a
Democrat of choice but you're so right i
did i did a piece way back when I worked
at HuffPost about Marco Rubio because he
said I'm not a scientist when he was
asked how old the earth is yeah he was
like I don't know 6,000 years old I
never he's like are you serious i'm not
i'm not a scientist and it really pissed
me off right and i went on this tirade
because i mean this is what i have to
say to you Ted Cruz like are you an
economist right are you a four-star
general because you have a lot of
wrong opinions about war and about
finances and but you're not a scientist
so you can't think it's just such a
[ __ ] cop right and that's the thing
you don't have to believe in it science
is happening whether you believe in it
or not it's not a something to give to
take a leap of faith to accept all right
so let's just talk about the political
part of this for a second because that's
the part that I think is particularly
interesting so Ted Cruz okay fine he
doesn't believe in climate change or
whatever it is so be it why do you think
the Republicans would have pointed to
this now I get it he's a powerful guy
right now the tea party's behind him but
like to me this doesn't seem like a
winning type of thing so what they're
they're in charge of NASA yeah i mean
that's that's the key to this they're in
charge of our space exploration and
they're putting a guy in charge of the
committee who doesn't believe in facts
because because he's going to have a lot
to do with budget allocation and they
don't want to be putting money towards
climate change the republican agenda is
that they think money should be going
elsewhere that's where all of this comes
down to they don't want to take federal
money and put it towards climate change
research which is a huge initiative at
NASA so he is probably going to start
systematically stripping NASA's budget
of any sort of initiatives that allow
them to actually monitor global co2
levels which is so [ __ ] scary so I
guess that goes to your point of having
some sort of what you call it a tech
tech knockers a technocracy because
we're politicizing science which is
completely insane yeah it is i mean what
if like you know they put him in charge
of like the brain initiative or
something you know that votes on stem
cell research and the ethics you know
like i think it's it's terrifying and
that has happened i mean bush put a huge
[ __ ] blog on stem cell research and yeah
let's not forget either that James
Inhofe is heading up the committee that
oversees the EPA and if you don't know
who James Inhofe is this is a guy who
not just denies anthropogenic climate
change but has actually said the words
something like global warming is the
greatest hoax perpetrated against the
American people he thinks it's
legitimately a hoax what are they what
are they trying to gain of course that I
don't PA okay so if I'm just if I was
trying to go along their lines of
thinking for a second what they think is
that the green movement as a whole is
did by people that are just pulling hook
so that they can make money very similar
to what the oil people are right like is
that you don't think they believe that
like I think they're they're trying they
like the idea that somehow al gore and
the rest of them are pushing these green
technologies on us because they own the
companies that are investing in I think
they've convinced themselves of that
because it's the only way to justify
continuing to take money from these oil
industry is I think it's kind of the
same way that if you were in bed with
big tobacco you would try and keep
figuring out a way to make sure that you
could justify that big tobacco is making
profit yeah and you might do it by
minimizing something else because I I
mean I can't imagine that somebody
actually believes that green technology
is taking like money out of the mouths
of America is like just insane breitling
industry to it'll create so many jobs
like well that's the and that's what I
mean about the economic part of it it's
like you know what if we invest in green
energies and then the oil industry is
hurt by that well we'll just shift jobs
elsewhere that's what that's what an
economy is supposed to do that's what
progress does you mean the coal industry
is it the same as it was 50 years ago
don't you think Ted Cruz is literally
thinking oh NASA's been allocating a lot
of money towards towards measuring co2
that's not a real issue you know I'm a
religious guy and I don't think that
only God can affect the climate and the
rapture is coming soon so we don't need
to worry about it instead I think NASA
should be um they should be working on
these satellites that we can put in
place for defense I really think that
that's probably yeah I pretty much agree
with you and I think he's mostly doing
things for political purposes I don't
even know what he acts cuz I do think
he's a smart human he's a smart person
so I don't know what his real beliefs
are yeah he's a politician and he's the
kind of the worst of the worst kind of
politician yeah so final thought on this
why do people fear science whenever we
do these stories on science I am
consistently amazed at the amount of
people we could parade up to just talk
about how science isn't real that things
that are proven aren't real meanwhile
they have iphones in their pocket right
they use they watch television i mean
everything else everything in life is
based in science i don't know i mean you
can probably speak better to this you
probably get your
of you know both sides of the fence
people that are obsessed with science
people they're haters I think people are
afraid of what they don't understand I
really think that that's fear breeds
kind of anger fear breeds like it's the
same reason that people are racist it's
the same reason that people are
homophobic it's because they don't
understand that culture they don't
understand that lifestyle and they
haven't been exposed to it and I don't
think that science literacy is where it
needs to be in our country I don't think
that we are doing an amazing job of
helping kids get into science early and
and continue to understand science and
because of that we have scientifically
illiterate adults who are afraid of what
they don't understand yeah the fine
folks over at kink University my alma
mater have sent out a survey to find out
the kinkiest cities in America they look
at things like you know where people are
doing BDSM fetishes and polyamorous
communities things of that nature and
we've got cities right here all right so
the top kinkiest cities Portland San
Francisco New York Chicago Washington DC
Los Angeles Seattle Boston Philly in
Vegas I mean it's basically cities with
a lot of people I portland's
particularly interesting and Philly so
we'll get to that in a sec and let's
just look at how they actually went
about doing this they looked at the
total size of the kink identified
population the size of the population
relative to the city's size the number
of resources available for kink
identified people and the adult
entertainment purchases in each city so
I don't know if you guys watch
Portlandia I love Portland yeah I've
actually never been to Portland I need
to go to Portland I grew up as a
portland Trail Blazer fan I always
wanted to go to Portland but there's
something going on in Portland right
like they wanna they let their freak
flags why Portland why Portland why is
that the number one kinkiest city do you
have any I what's going on in the water
in the Pacific Northwest put a bird on
it had any kink segments like sketches I
don't think yeah well all the characters
are just so out there I guess that you
would expect them to be doing this none
of them look like they would actually
get laid if nothing true but I
we know from like you know businessmen
in Japan there's this big thing where
they like to be a lot of them like tied
up and beaten and abused know that so
it's not just what people look like on
the outside that indicates what they
like I've read that that Portland is the
only city in the u.s. that has a dormant
volcano within its city life so maybe
there's like some of that yeah meru made
it yeah it's true so maybe or meet
volcano and portly that's what I read
yeah so maybe there's some kind of weird
existential thing going on with all the
there they're all like we could die and
yes fly the freak flag loud proud yeah
we just throw the city's up one more
time real quick because what i thought
was interesting that these are all
basically big cities I'm in San
Francisco New York Chicago well they're
all know Holly coastal cities except for
Vegas right now in philly I guess
Phyllis no Phyllis Billy's postal enough
so but all of these seem like kind of
cool cities to me the only one doesn't
strike me as a cool city is philly
philly really is an awesome saying
really when I lived in New York I was
but I started my PhD in New York and I
hated it and I get a lot of heat from
the county by their very angry and yeah
and I was miserable and it's cold my
lived in Queens and it was a beautiful
neighborhood and forest hills but I
didn't know anybody whatever and one of
my best friend's was a medical school in
philly and i would take the chinatown
bus to philly risk my life on the
chinatown bus literally every weekend to
spend time in center city in philly
because i was so obsessed with philly
yeah it's a great it's got reading
terminal it's got there's so much cool
stuff and they got that Bell like that
Bell broken building mutter museum yeah
come on all right let's not focus on
Philly too much either of you dated
anyone of that was particularly
interested in any sort of kink max go
have I uh you are on the spy let's go I
my pen right I don't think so i think
they've all been somewhat vanilla that's
my most politically correct wow that was
boring Cara give me something here I
know you've definitely been you've got a
lip ring in for God's sake maybe I don't
know I don't know how do you define kink
well like no ladies marez I've never
really tried I mean I've dated
non-monogamous Lee before but I've never
been in the poly community I have a lot
of friends actually weirdly in the poly
community but I don't think that would
be for me I get too jealous yeah um I
dated a guy once who was like a peer
cyst and he was really into like
pain so here it so what did he want you
always wanted to like no I he didn't
want me to do anything but he always
wanted to like Pierce himself like
during and I never was okay wait he
wanted to pierce during sex here's a
peer cyst and he liked it alligator so
you're having sex hygienic Li like
weirded out by it so I didn't do it wait
so you'd literally be having sex and he
wanted wanna pierce himself yeah like
his armors while you were having sex
yeah because it like it felt good to him
so he used to he and another piercer
friend or another he worked at a tattoo
shop they used to pierce you know they
would do surface piercings in their
backs or do other things and just take
them out that night they only did it to
like play with designs and because it
felt good yeah a little weird wow I
things hurt like hell to me and I don't
get any sort of like sexual excitement
out of it but I don't think it's the
weirdest kink thing out there I could
see why some people might get sexual
excited I've been in a girl that would
growl during a weird is it here wish
your part wolf yeah I think she might
have been did you like it I think not
really growl like what give us I mean I
can't right so it was a weird primordial
a little thing like right it was a bird
it was more of a growl freak me out um
so I know these stories are all kind of
see what's your story day oh thank you
like yeah not you know i I've been tied
up I've been at up yeah do you think the
kink is more it had nothing to do with
sex I've just been do you think it's
more intense in the LGBT community cuz I
know walking I like English yeah like on
Santa Monica Boulevard they're
definitely like leather shops and you
see a lot of change and people identify
that like [ __ ] masks and things often to
write with gay-sex not as much what I
don't know that's actually you know I
live in West Hollywood which is like the
the hub of the gay community at least in
Los Angeles and there's this like very
intense leather store just a couple
blocks away from where i live and i
always think it's so interesting because
it's not it makes no difference may I
walk by it means nothing to me I'll take
anything weird like that I know there's
some weird they got some weird stuff
like it doesn't strike me any which way
but I know if that was in a more in a
straight community it would be thought
of differently than it does
dallas texas right well that's what i
mean like a ball gag like in the window
and yet it's fully in the window there
so I yep I mean gay the gay community in
general does view sex differently or a
little freer I think less uptight
they're less uptight you know it's the
outsider thing anyway what weird [ __ ]
are you into you let us know in the
comments right down below millions of
genetically modified mosquitoes could be
released in Florida basically to stop to
very painful viral diseases I'm gonna do
a little reading here because I want to
get the science right cuz as I said I
got two bright people with me uh the
dang the dengue am i right dengue dengue
and the chikungunya yes chikungunya
chikungunya viral diseases can okay
pretty good so far our growing threats
in the US and with global warming with
climate change spreading tropical
diseases farther from the equator storm
winds cargo ships and humans carry these
viruses to southern cities in the u.s.
like the Florida Keys so there's an
explosion of this in Florida right now
there were no vaccines or cures for
either of these two diseases and many
more people now are being basically are
afraid of being bitten by a GMO organism
because then that could start a whole
other set of problems anyway so more
than 130,000 people have signed a
change.org petition trying to stop these
GMO mosquitoes from being released yeah
we're good okay I'm feeling pretty good
about this anyway the head of the
Florida medical entomology laboratory
had this to say I think the science is
fine they definitely can kill mosquitoes
but GMO issue still sticks as something
of a thorny issue for the general public
I'm on their side and that consequences
are highly unlikely but to say there's
no genetically modified DNA that might
get into a human that's kind of a gray
matter okay so as you can tell by my
lead into this this is not my department
so I want Kara can you clean up this a
little bit because there's a couple
issues here there's general fear of
diseases there's GMO stuff yeah there's
fear of disease there's fear of
of genetically modified organisms and I
think that the the link between the two
we need to make sure is clear so the
reason that these GM mosquitoes that
have been developed in a UK lab and have
been successfully deployed I think in
brazil and i think in one other area in
South America Central America and
actually did reduce the population the
way it works is that these genetically
modified mosquitoes have been modified
to contain some sort of protein some
sort of coding region in their DNA that
allows them to successfully mate with
disease-carrying mosquitoes or any
mosquitoes of the species that they're
trying to target and produce offspring
that's not viable so basically it it
kills off the population because these
modified mosquitoes can't persist so the
idea is we can't kill billions of
mosquitoes right but what we can do is
release mosquito is that it through
through reproduction will end up
dramatically reducing the population of
disease-carrying mosquitoes so this to
me is a question of again kind of First
World privilege this we've talked about
GMOs a lot yeah and I obviously have
been very kind of outspoken about being
pro GM oh yeah and one example that I
would use is that there there was a rice
that was developed called golden rice
and golden rice was developed in an
effort to provide nutrition that wasn't
present in certain parts of the world
and Greenpeace because of their fear of
GM technology successfully stopped
golden rice from being delivered and it
has been estimated that literally
millions multiple millions of people
could have lives could have been saved
if Golden Rice had been released and I
worry that this is the same kind of a
situation where because people don't
understand the science they're willing
to cockblock something that could
prevent a lot of people from suffering
really debilitating illnesses right ok
so you did a much better job of clear by
the way I presented it so there's sort
of two things happening here one the GMO
is in general people fear sort of
irrationally almost everything we eat is
genetically modified right our bananas
aren't are there no such thing as
regular bananas anymore seventy and
ninety percent of the
foods on your grocery store shelves if
you're not shopping at a place that
specifically caters towards that yeah
has some ingredient this unit right and
that doesn't mean that it's killing you
or doing anything bad there's literally
there's no evidence out there at all
that it has any negative effects on
health or human safety the only concerns
that most people the only legitimate
concerns about GM technology our crop
concerns their concerns about spreading
crops and taking over other fields and
you know when you develop something
that's a crop that's drought resistant
and that you know is really Hardy yes it
might not die if and when you try to
kill it right so okay so then that that
gets me to my next question which is I
think most people have this conflation
between GMOs and Monsanto yeah yeah and
Monsanto has strange business practices
related to the crops and what people can
use season after season and things I'm
not even asking you a question there but
I feel like there's no no I mean I feel
like it's it's very necessary to
separate to parse those two out yeah i
think that like in the hands of a
company like monsanto that seeks only a
profit motive I mean it's dangerous but
I love the Golden Rice analogy there's
another really recent one that I love so
in Uganda children are deficient in
vitamin A and it's got a real you know
stunting problem with the growth of
children a lot of them are you know
experienced vision problems because
they're so deficient in vitamin A and so
you mentioned bananas they're now trying
to or they're able to actually modify
bananas so there are a lot higher in
vitamin A and to prevent these sorts of
you know this mal nourishment in Uganda
and it's amazing and i think the minute
we start vilifying you know in the broad
sense genetically modifying organisms i
think it's super dangerous right and
going back to mosquitoes like the males
that they're talking about modifying
aren't even the ones that bite right
yeah the modified mosquitoes are the non
biting mosquitoes they're just worried
that a handful of females might make it
into the crop and that a handful of
those female mosquitoes might bite you
but why do I give a [ __ ] if a
genetically modified mosquito bites me
that maybe contains like a handful of
proteins that prevent it from being able
to make viable offspring I would be much
more concerned about getting bitten by a
mosquito carrying chikungunya right why
you said that well with total confidence
ooh ok so it try to help me understand
this so the people that don't like GMOs
in this case what they would argue
I guess is that we're going to create a
super strain of mosquitoes that
eventually we won't be able to control I
mean there's that that's what their
argument I don't think that they can
articulate what they're afraid would
happen I don't think that there is a
valid scientific argument for what would
happen I think it is that kind of well
we don't know because we haven't tested
it and it could have some sort of
runaway consequence that we can't
foresee in the future and I get that but
isn't that with all science is about you
I couldn't use caution when we think
about that and yes you can look
historically at drugs that were
developed that people took that then
caused really big problems and had to be
taken off the market because we didn't
do enough testing I totally understand
that concern but at the same time would
you throw the baby out with the
bathwater would you never take another
pill again right and that's that's the
irony of these people that believe in
science half the time and then don't
believe it the other hand it's yes we're
some before it's like people were just
afraid of what they don't understand
yeah so is this just one of those issues
I mean again the way I presented this
thing up top I don't really get all this
stuff but I I'm trying to do stuff like
this just so that people that have a few
minutes can get a little bit of
something on this but is this just one
of these things where people just won't
take the time to learn about so that's
why it's never discussed like that's why
this is the type of story that doesn't
make it to CNN or fox or whatever
because there's just like a lot of big
words and you have to think about it for
a second so people just don't talk about
it yeah and I think that people's
opinions are easily swayed by clickbait
headlines too i don't think that those
help the cause um but yeah i mean i
think people need to this is like our
world you know and it's rapidly changing
now more so than ever before people need
to take the time to to read up and i
think what you said is an important
point because we in the media have to
take responsibility for this problem too
i mean if we are the ones presenting
these stories just like the article that
we read leading up to this to this
segment a lot of the headlines are gonna
be like GMO mosquitoes millions of jim
could be releasing your neighborhood
danger danger and if that's how we
presented of course it's going to make
people afraid but if we prevent a if we
present it in a really balanced way I
think people will understand that this
kind of technology which might be scary
because you don't understand it can have
really positive implication yeah all
right well on that note we will link to
the story that we're talking about down
below so you can actually do some more
research and learn a little something
The Bulletin of Atomic Scientists say
that the earth is now closer
doomsday than ever before that's right
they've been tracking this stuff for a
while and they basically use like a
clock to say how close we are to pretty
much destroying ourselves or the earth
just destroying us or some compilation
thereof we've got some info for you so
the u.s. advocacy group founded by the
creators of the atomic bomb move their
famous doomsday clock ahead two minutes
it said that the world is now three
minutes from a catastrophic midnight
instead of five minutes so let's just
look at the timeline for a second here
so in case it isn't clear exactly what's
happening here basically they're taking
our day is sort of the timeline for
Humanity and then they're factoring in
all these different things between
global warming and nuclear weapons and
other political geopolitical things and
saying how close we are to destroying
ourselves or you know some sort of
either man-made catastrophe or something
with the earth getting rid of us so 1984
they said we were three minutes away to
midnight now that was in the heat of the
Cold War so obviously there was a threat
of atomic war all the time 1991 we were
17 minutes so that's seven years later
and then we were further away from
strong ourselves cuz 1991 things were
basically pretty good the Cold War was
gone and the earth seemed to be in a
pretty good state then in 2002 we got
closer to midnight again and this is
shortly after nine eleven obviously and
then as you can see in 2012 we were a
little closer and now into that's
between three minutes to midnight okay
so technically we're not three minutes
away you're gonna make it through this
video I promise you but I think these
things are kind of interesting it again
we're doing a bunch of sciency stuff
with you guys so there's something
there's some science behind this and
then there's also like a little I don't
know what can we call this is it just
kind of fantasies it is a bit it's a bit
arbitrary the numbers right right well
it's like really like strict algorithm
that they use to come right like this
but yeah obviously after the Cold War
when we started to see nations being
involved in nuclear arms reduction talks
people started to feel a lot safer and I
think the interesting thing is that
historically the Doomsday Clock really
had almost
everything to do with nuclear war but
now these scientists are saying okay
nuclear war is still a risk but global
warming is it like an equivalent risk
and so we have to really take that into
account because when we talk about
doomsday and we talked about the end of
humanity we could be wiping ourselves
off the face of the earth because of
climate change yeah do you fear man-made
disasters or just natural disasters more
as our way that we're gonna we're gonna
go down yeah I don't I think I think
that we definitely have the potential to
you know to blow ourselves up but I in
the article uh Steven Pinker was
referenced who says that we live in the
least violent times ever yeah all of
history but like you know because of the
24-hour news cycle if it bleeds it leads
on you know mainstream media like it's
Stokes our amygdala right which fires up
our fight-or-flight so we have the sense
that we're living in really violent time
so we're actually not so I'm not really
that concerned but we're also living in
a climate where we don't have to be that
violent overall to see mass destruction
because it only takes one crazy person
with access to very strong weapons and
the farther and farther along we get the
more that we're seeing individuals who
maybe have no right and granted this is
coming from an American who thinks that
we have no right to have nuclear weapons
either um but it you know the fire power
has increased exponentially so it takes
a small group of people with a lot of
firepower to do a lot of damage when
historically the firepower was less
intense so more people needed to be
violent right so for example in the Cold
War we had mutual deterrence basically
if we were gonna do anything they were
gonna blow us up to and now there's so
many smaller actors and the threat of a
dirty bomb exactly North Korea Iran you
know what happens if Isis gets involved
and like those are the kinds of things
where I personally I'm not like you know
staying up at night but it does worry me
because there are people who because of
religious implications don't have any
concept of kind of shepherding the earth
for many years to come because they
literally think that like the end is
nigh I mean they literally want it they
wanted better they think they're going
to heaven right which is batshit crazy
and so that like that you really feel
exactly that's what worries me most is
when you
have when you have an actor who is not
afraid of the ramifications of their
actions all of a sudden that person with
the gun becomes a lot more dangerous
yeah do you guys think this is why we
have to explore space I mean it seems to
me that at some point here and you could
every sci-fi movie that they go on any
adventure anywhere I mean what was the
one with Matthew McConaughey just a
couple months ago you're selling
interstellar I mean this is what you
know that we're gonna travel the cosmos
to find another planet that will sustain
life because we're gonna screw up this
whole thing I mean is this the whole
point why we have to put money I think
into NASA I don't really think that
we're gonna be alive to see the fruition
of those searches but you know I do look
to guys like Richard Branson an Elon
Musk and I'm like these guys have the
right idea because I mean we are on some
kind of trajectory for sure but I you
know I try to remain optimistic you know
I think that um I think everything's
gonna be okay let's remember here we
with you know global climate change
which i think is probably the talking
point of this article specifically it's
less now about nuclear war but with
global climate change we have the
potential and we are actively destroy
not the earth per se but ourselves ya
know the famous quote in and write the
first alarm yes is that life will find a
way like the cockroaches probably won't
die off yeah we are killing ourselves
off we are making the climate not
habitable for humankind anymore and
that's something we have to remember is
that really the best way to fo to frame
it because when you say it in that sense
like people think the earth is just
gonna explode but that's really not
what's gonna happen we're just going to
change things to the point where our
species the things that we need to
survive the water we need to drink in
the air we need to breathe etc will not
work it wants to say that we there have
been major climactic events in the past
and they've been mass extinctions and we
are gearing up for one and we are
contributing to it that's the crazy
thing we are exacerbating this well if
it happens then I guess the aliens will
come here and then right then our bones
will be buried deep which will turn into
oil that the aliens are news is that has
anyone brought that theory
what do you think let us know in the
comments right down below so I thought
this was really fascinating doctors have
been working on a test to find out if
elderly patients will die within 30 days
and the reason they're doing this is so
that they can decide what kind of
treatment people want do they want to
just send people home so that they can
be with their loved ones do they want to
try experimental medicines things of
that nature so we've got a little more
info for you the checklist will prevent
futile and expensive medical treatments
which merely prolonged suffering the
test looks at 29 indicators of health
including age illness mental impairment
previous emergency admissions and heart
rate and produces a percentage chance of
death within one month and 12 weeks
it'll provide a starting point for
honest talk with patients and families
about recognizing the dying is part of
the life cycle but I think this is
fascinating at many levels I don't think
we talk about death enough it's one of
the two things what's the other one
taxes there you go that we all have to
do in life and it is part of the circle
of life so this actually seems pretty
interesting to me in my own personal
life with two of my grandmother's they
both sort of had beautiful endings where
we had a week with them and everyone was
able to be there one of my grandma's
went into hospice and we were all able
to say goodbye and all that kind of
stuff but there are so many examples
where we keep people on machines for an
extremely long amount of time and by the
way this study is not about young people
that maybe are in a coma or agitated
this is about old people that are not
going to come out the other side this is
this is kind of this is sort of what
science is all about yeah yeah I think I
think it's actually great I mean a few
people know this but medical care is the
third leading cause of death in the
United States there are literally 12,000
people year that died due to unnecessary
surgeries and so at the end of a
person's life we're able to say okay
look enough is enough we're not gonna
like try anything too crazy you know
we're gonna let this person like live
out the rest of their natural life and I
think that's a good thing yeah I just
worried that we would never see this
happen in the United States this is a
British initiative and yeah or a UK
initiative and the truth of the matter
is we have this weird this weird kind of
concept in America of like push push
push push push until the end the idea
that p
well that assisted suicide is completely
against the law except we're like in
Oregon I think is one of the only state
yeah maybe there's a couple of others
now we're and not even assisted suicide
but uh what's the word I'm looking for
def by dignity is not dead death by
dignity is what they have yeah that's
that's kind of the bill that is a step
in the right direction I think that this
is like a no-brainer step in the right
direction but I bet you if we tried to
pass a law like that people would really
push back yes so why is it that the
religious people the ones that believe
in heaven right the ones that believe in
the afterlife are also the people that
want to keep everybody on machines there
there you know I mean they want you to
go to the netherworld and then at the
same time they want to keep you here be
a science it's like again this goes
we've had a real theme with this episode
but there's this strange disconnect
between we all have that in these really
emotional situations but the truth is I
think in practice more individuals would
actually you know if it was your mother
if it was your brother or sister you
would want to make the decision that
that ease their suffering but i think
that when we step away from it and we
think about it in global terms there's
this intense fear i think and i don't
know if it's coming specifically from
the right or specifically from the
religious right i should say but there's
this intense fear that like I don't want
a doctor making a decision about when I
live or die and what if the doctor does
that and I get that like this checklist
for example yes not well tested I would
like to see a year of this being
implemented but not actually like where
somebody comes in you do the checklist
and then you wait and you see how long
it actually takes and insane right so
there's they're just the beginning
exactly because I kind of understand
that minor fear that crops up in
somebody's mind where they go oh well my
grandma came in and she could have lived
five more years but they did that doctor
decided that she didn't deserve any more
treatment and who is he to do that so I
get that concern but at the same time
this idea of dying with dignity yeah i
think is such an important thing we need
to be exploring i love that yeah back to
your part I feel like they're just
hedging their bets like just in case of
their idea heaven news Yeah right vision
you know they're pretty into it until
they had
they really bring up to shove yeah but I
think we would all be that way I think
all of us would say I don't know you
know I'm I'll be ready for it when it
happens to land then right before like
have you ever watched somebody die yeah
it's a really intense experience and
it's not uncommon for in those final
throes people to go like I'm really
scared like of course are scared that's
what everybody's thinking about their
whole lives it's something to be afraid
of and so at the very end you might know
I changed my mind this isn't what I want
unfortunately that's where life takes
you yeah do you think part of the thing
that will muck this whole thing up yeah
we need to obviously find out a little
more the evidence of how this will all
work is the fear of the legal stuff
which i think is partly what you were
alluding to there that people are going
to sign something and say okay I'm gonna
let them go home and then after 30 days
someone's gonna still be alive and then
they're gonna go all right now we're
gonna be in a lawsuit like this is just
where I think partly that's why we don't
have the proper discussion about death
and circle of life because then lawyers
get involved and everybody fights about
everything the bureaucracy of death the
business of death yeah it's crazy um but
I think that I think that initiatives
like this will go a long way towards at
the very least igniting conversation we
TV has put out a trailer for sex box
what is sex box I'll take a look welcome
to sex box it's a little intimidating no
background now
it can take 30 minutes 40 minutes for a
woman to be fully aroused feels like I
just lost my virginity I felt like it
was my fault I'm still here i'm not
gonna run away I'm not shutting down to
say yes to sexual acts with your
partners to say yes to love and say yes
to commit alright so to be clear in case
you're not sure what's happening there
these people are just having sex in the
box there's no camera in the box there's
no they're not we're not hearing them
we're not watching them have sex they're
just having sex in the box and then they
come out of the box and then they talk
about it with you know some therapist
there's a podcaster they'll probably
throw some comedians on there um this
just seems so silly to me like we live
in an age where I don't know if you know
this but there is porn on I know there's
a lot of nudity out there the idea that
they'd have a show where then you're not
even watching it I when I first saw this
when our producer said this to me about
all right well the idea that you know
you of therapist or something would
watch people have sex and then they'd
all analyzed it that actually seems sort
of interesting to me the idea that
they're just having sex in there and
then they come out and talk about it I
mean this just seems this just seems so
backwards to sort of the progress we've
made in terms of sexual freedom and and
distilling stuff that we do in the
bedroom and all that even beyond that
like I don't understand how this is good
television alright like you're saying
this was a rich on WE TV no one said
it's good to this is it was a british
show first yeah and it didn't do well
there why are we adapting it for
American television cause like it had
horrible ratings there nobody watched it
this reminds me so much of that black
mirror episode all right yeah we talked
about black yeah which one the one where
the guy has to pay 15 million oh yeah
don't give your way don't give it I
don't think I saw that one yes the first
one in the list adresa yeah first so I
did see that one yeah it's just like
yeah like the lengths that people will
go to for a sense of like validation in
their lives i'm gonna go have sex in a
box on TV yeah sorry but doesn't show
like
this now in 2015 the way sex has changed
because of the intern and the way we can
talk about it and the things that we can
see doesn't this just seemed absurd like
to me if this was 2004 and this show
came out I think maybe there would be
something to it you know it but now
we're just so past the point and it's
all so silly like it's just silly to be
talking like you will you had sex you
don't need to cut you know like yeah I
think that's just slowly just like
anything else any other reality TV it's
kind of engineered conflict I'm assuming
that the casting is going to be based on
cup because these are couples they're
not even like two random people having
sex it's like people who have sex all
the time now they're gonna have sex in
this box so i think that the ideas
they're gonna be cash that's a great
point about that because that that would
be another that would be an interesting
idea for random people random people
having sex and then yeah like then
without your first gay experience in the
concert that's a sure but like yeah but
the idea that it's just like couples i
think they're probably going to cast for
couples with like [ __ ] up problems
they're gonna cast for a woman who's
afraid that he's been cheating they're
gonna cast for a couple who's been
having sexual problems so then they but
then that's just depressing and also i
have a real problem i do a lot of
edgerton meant television that's you
know what I pay the bills with and so
and a lot of times they put that under
the banner of reality so I meet with
people at production companies and net
networks and we talk about reality TV
and my one thing that I always say is
that I don't do humiliation television
just I as a general rule I would never
be involved in a television show cup
where that's the focus yeah that's what
i call it and this to me is pure and and
you know unbridled humiliation
television yeah it's getting into the
fucked-up lives of people and so that
you can feel better about your own
situation that's that's why people enjoy
this kind of probably control for
performance anxiety because i would
imagine that i'm like a major factor
yeah well i guess that would be more of
a factor if people were actually
watching you but again there's no
cameras in the box yeah you know there's
people sitting right outside the sun
waiting for you to finish I guess your
match the next show is going to be like
pee in a urinal right yeah you're in a
little bar gonna be like
can't pee you guys are watching me I'm
yeah I get that I've got 10 faucet on
get you weird you get weird in the
bathroom um I mean I ting but we do have
a rash of these shows right like there's
dating naked and naked and afraid' which
I actually think is pretty pretty decent
um but again it's this weird thing with
sex that seems so it just seemed so
immature to me oh this show would never
do well in like France or Germany or
play there like why do I I don't
understand the fact that i may get
people in commercial right big damn war
isn't like we still women's
entertainment or is up in riva i think
they've rebranded like 18 times over
yeah it's like TLC it's like no longer
you don't learn it anyway whatever are
you down with sex and box let us know in
the comments right down below are you a
smoker it is tough to be a smoker in
2015 and now the UK is going to try to
make it even more difficult they want to
pass a law that would basically remove
all branding from cigarettes so we've
got an image of what the new boxes would
look like so basically they're going to
have the warnings now we have these
warnings here in America too and this is
all over the world right now where they
just show you some really scary [ __ ] of
what it can do to your lungs and your
mouth and your teeth and your gums and
all that and then the brand name would
just be on the bottom but it wouldn't
involve Joe the camel there wouldn't be
anything that looks cool or interesting
or anything like that and now we've got
a little bit more info on the proposed
bill under the proposed regulations
packets would have to have mandatory
colors the current proposal shows a
brown packet on the outside which is
white inside the brand and product names
are the only items of the text that the
company can add the new packets would
have health warnings such as smoking
damages your lungs tobacco smoke
contains over 70 substances known to
cause cancer all right so this isn't
that different but it is sort of the
next step in this uh but the part that I
think is interesting about this is we
have done so much with smoking it is so
changed now we're here in LA so I get it
were on the people are a little more
into health care a little more conscious
I never see anyone smoking pretty much a
couple do I think my director smoke we
don't see that many we don't see that
many people smoking um so do you think
the the people at this point that want
to smoke does this going this much
further do you think this
stops anybody it did in Australia in
Australia this was passed and this is
mimicking that law and they did the
whole like you know nondescript
packaging with the warnings and so
because a lot from the colorful boxes
and stow oh that's my brand and if you
don't identify any more with the kind of
marketing behind your brand it might not
feel as connected but in Australia they
did this and I think smoking went down
from like fifteen percent to twelve
percent what it worked I mean that's why
they're doing it and the truth is I
think the government needs to do what
they can but at the same time we have
agency I'm not all about outlawing new
drugs I want to decriminalize the old
drugs like people are gonna smoke if
they can smoke but for sure and I used
to be a smoker I smoked for many many
years and it was very hard for me to
quit now I run every other day and I'll
tell you that it's not uncommon for me
to be running in my neighborhood and
there's a dude on the corner smoking a
cigarette and like in my run I'm like
you know like I'm breathing like
cigarette air while I'm running yeah
there is a guy i kid you not that I play
basketball every sunday and there's a
guy that we play with that literally
smokes in between game yeah and I cannot
believe it and then he's hacking up a
lot like he's literally hacking up and
spitting on the side of the court while
we're playing and I haven't said
anything new but I want to look in and
be like dude do you see the connection
perhaps he does and he's probably doing
he's doing the best thing honestly cuz
most smokers aren't active so the truth
is the more active you are the easier it
is for you to quit because you actually
get that negative feedback which a lot
of people don't have yeah when I was a
smoker and i was like i know i need to
quit but i don't feel the negative
effects of smoking and until i do i'm
not gonna feel the motivation to quit
when i started to feel the negative
effects of smoking I was like holy [ __ ]
that's interesting so should we then
take all the regulations off cigarettes
let them make that make it as
carcinogenic or whatever as possible
then people maybe would feel it more and
everything kids are gonna smoke then
kids again I mean that's the whole
reason behind like getting rid of you
know the camel and the bright coloring
anyway unless it's it's against the law
i think here to have flavored cigarettes
yeah cuz kids will want to smoke yeah i
think some regulation is good i think
that um that this is a really extreme
you know measure to take but uh you know
I'm for it like you said I mean if the
research proves that less people will
smoke because they identify less with
the brand and the pretty color isn't it
you know I think that's awesome and
that's the Surgeon General's job like
that's the job of people in this or or
whatever the British equivalent of what
is that's the job of people in those
positions of powers to bring the public
as much knowledge as possible and so if
they say this warning maybe it's
something people don't know or maybe
they just you need that cognitive do you
need to force it like I want to see it
every time I pick up the cigarette
disease long yeah but just in fact to
play devil's advocate like what if they
start doing that with like fast food you
know they should they should be very
easy world yeah right so that's that's
calorie counts down now right so that's
the slippery slope and I remember when I
lived in New York City and they were
putting calorie counts on all the
restaurants and there were restaurants
it was something like if you had more
than six locations in manhattan or
something you had to do it so there were
some restaurants that actually closed
locations so that they wouldn't have to
put the calories nobody would want to
buy their 7,000 calories right but even
something like olive garden in new york
city had to start putting the calories
and i would go and i'd see that you know
like this like fettuccine alfredo was
something like 4,000 calories don't
quote me on that exactly but that
literally you're having almost double
the amount of calories to get in a day
so some of this stuff does actually so
it does yeah but I am but as a general
rule i'm leery of life too much go
government oversight but there's a
difference between ban you know banning
you know a large soda in new york city
is totally different than putting
information is gonna be information yeah
i don't see anything wrong with that
yeah so last autumn you guys surprised
the e-cigarettes are working like it's
actually working you know we don't have
advertisements you can't have
commercials regular cigarettes but there
are shitload of commercials for anything
and Jenny McCarthy thank you for
bringing that up Jenny McCarthy who you
know is completely against vaccines but
somehow she has no problem doing I think
it's blue cigarettes or whatever that
e-cigarette thing is so is that sort of
the disheartening part of this like
we've done so much good with getting
people to stop smoking cigarettes but
we've just now shifted them into
something like that's what's gonna
happen always there's gonna be a profit
profit motive and it's gonna be co-opted
in order to make money and that's what's
so dangerous ecigarettes are almost
equivalent Lee dangerous as dangerous as
regular cigarettes they're very very bad
for you and I totally understand them as
a tool to help
quit because the nice thing about
e-cigarettes is you can calibrate how
much nicotine is in them so you start
with a full cigarette you can go down to
half the nicotine go down to a quarter
of the nicotine and eventually just be
smoking non nicotine right and I'd get
all of it yeah but I wonder how many
people are exactly and that's the sad
thing this could have been a really good
therapeutic tool but instead people are
just smoking e-cigarettes now instead of
regular cigarettes and none of the
regulations are in place yeah all right
what do you think do you smoke are we
government agents that are trying to
control how many calories and how much
caffeine and tobacco and all that stuff
you put in your body let us know in the
comments right down below I want to
thank Cara and Max their twitters are
right down below as well I think this
was this was pretty smart and I got
through the science stuff pretty
decently so proud of you I'm feeling
good alright I'm taking the rest of the
day off okay thanks for watching
everybody we'll do it again next week